schmeckt sehr lecker wie eine ganz
normale cola aber ist ja auch logisch
das einzige manko
ich rede immer wenn ich diese erstens
videos machen das einzige mann
herzlich willkommen beim ein video jahre
alte ich hoffe natürlich euch jetzt
keine angst ich bin nicht irgendwie
stark krank oder so ich habe gerade
geduscht und das shampoo hat sich
irgendwie allergisch auf meine haut
ausgewählt deswegen bin ich gerade noch
ein bisschen rot im gesicht hatte ich
auch noch nie brennt auch ein bisschen
aber darum soll es heute natürlich gar
nicht gehen und zwar steht heute ein
video an was ich euch natürlich noch
schuldig bin ich habe nämlich bereits
gesagt wo wir glaube ich bei einer
pizzeria zufällig bestellt haben hier
heute bei 10.000 nix machen wir das
ganze mal in irgendeinem fast food laden
oder so das geht ja auch und ich habe
mir an dieser stelle mein burger
rausgesucht wir haben jetzt gerade
gearbeitet ich goethe zu hause und habe
mir gedacht wir kommen kannst halt mal
ganz entspannt das video drehen und mal
gucken was heute so der lieferdienste
vorbeibringen ich würde sagen wir machen
es wie immer bei 10,6 gibt es im
nächsten license partout wirklich
bestellen oder so und ja ich will
eigentlich erich angela aber wir fangen
sofort an
ich bin hier schon auf der burger king
liefer seite und die liefern nur noch
eine stunde deswegen müssen sie jetzt
auch ein bisschen beeilen
das kann jetzt auch mal wieder weggehen
hier ist das ja noch viel schlimmer ja
neben der kamera ist noch eine nette
assistentin nämlich heute ein bisschen
assistiert wieder mit den zufallszahlen
habe ich hoffe dir geht's gut ich musste
so durch wie man sehen kann befinden wir
uns jetzt auf der lieferantenseite von
burger king place plant übrigens noch
mal zur erinnerung wir uns erst mal ein
paar bewertung an weil das ganze hat nur
dreieinhalb sterne essen kam erst nach
fast zwei stunden war heiß und hat
geschmack nach zwei stunden kann mich so
lange behalten liefe 105 minuten länger
gedauert als angeben es war kalt und
matschig ich warte immer noch auf meinen
bis das fleisch verband kommen ist und
beide der bestellungen nicht gewesen der
lieferant entschuldigt sich mit der
begründung dass es ihr erster tag ist
und sie keine deutsch sprechen könne
es ist bettruhe was hat denn bitte das
essen damit zu tun dass sie kein deutsch
kann hier bestellt auf jeden fall hier
lassen uns das auch nie fahren weil im
endeffekt ist das ja auch eine message
an euch damit ihr halt besser nicht bei
bürgern gestellt wenn es schlecht ist
aber das weiß man ja nie 19 mal habe ich
bestimmt an um 20 uhr 30 habe ich an
mir gesagt das essen unterwegs ist um 31
habe ich nochmal an wo man dann haben
wir wieder gesagt hast das essen
unterwegs ist also ich hoffe dass wir
das ist wirklich heute bekommen wir
switchen zurück auf die menükarte haben
hier 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 kategorie
vielleicht prinzip für immer gefangen
mit der ersten kategorie du musst jetzt
mal würfeln
also leute wir haben hier die 6 1 2 3 4
5 6 burger so leute also wir sind jetzt
hier bei den bürgern gekostet nur der
burger der rob huff schon fünf euro das
finde ich ganz schön teuer
gut das wird natürlich geliefert aber
trotzdem im laden kostet er mal nicht
euro weniger wir nichts über meer okay
aber bitte die 15 12 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 13 14 15 land schicken edel finde ich
sogar ganz locker fünf euro zurück okay
okay leute wir haben willst du den mit
bacon ohne mario ohne salat
manchmal mache ich bin immer auf leicht
rot und wir haben jetzt hier 499 im
warenkorb die nächste kategorie
betreiber die halo 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
wir haben gesagt okay gut ist halt so
und jetzt einmal die zahl der 1 2 3 4 5
6 7
ja okay das wäre jetzt theoretisch wenn
man halt durchgehend der donut mit
füllung und den wollte ich euch mal
probieren
ok 658 willkommen zunächst kategorie
hier sind reicht ja auch mal okay
willkommen zur nächsten kategorie und
zwar die 2 bacon weeks 659 für den
bürger von burger king so okay jetzt bin
ich gespannt ist im spiegel darauf nehme
weil das würde ich ja gar nicht feiern
aber ich finde so viel fleisch echt ist
nicht so mein ding vor allem wenn es ein
burger king ist habe ich ein schlechtes
gewissen 9 eur 59 für einen burger king
menü alles klar flughafen preise
wollen wir cola zu trinken oder oder ein
bier okay wir haben es in den warenkorb
und sind jetzt bei 16 eur 42 eine sache
noch dann rechts sowie auf mehr schafft
wenig oder hast du sagen losnummer echt
okay leute willkommen jetzt okay wir
filme 123 ja auch hier ist elf drinks ja
gut haben wir beim fangen nicht
verarschen weitere 24 für sein bier und
drei euro 4 findet cola wieso ist das so
teuer 1 1 23
willst du noch eine cola damit okay
leute jetzt wirklich die allerletzte
sache dann kann juli auch noch was haben
und zwar 7 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 king snacks
denn 1 2 3 4 5 kg 24 eur 39 für kinder
gibt im endeffekt wenn ich jetzt
bestellen würde weiß ich ganz genau ist
einem kommentar ich finde sie nicht
wieso bestellt zusammen deswegen würde
ich sagen wir setzen jetzt hier mal kurz
ein jogger ein und wird mir noch mal
oder okay sagt meine zeit in der
gleichen kategorie dann okay 123456 20
kinder gibt es okay noch mal okay 1 ja
das wäre eine kleine pommes nochmals
maximum ist ok und die pommes noch ein
wir sind jetzt insgesamt bei mit ketchup
oder pommes frites was ist das das
interessiert mich jetzt mal okay kaufen
22 eur 45 haben jetzt hier den link
schicken dort mit fulham bin ich sehr
gespannt drauf becken king menü coca
cola zero
man muss ja immer in die figur denke das
war bei light oder das war bei light
oder und die king kommen ist für 3 euro
und jetzt haben wir ein absolutes
schnäppchen gemacht und zwar 22 eur 45
okay leute wir bestellen das jetzt und
dann bin ich gespannt wann das ankommen
seine bestellung wird bearbeitet wird
jetzt weiter geht dann bin ich habe auch
gerade schon die bestätigungs mail
bekommen ihre bestellung ist eingegangen
und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt wir haben
jetzt ein 20 uhr 47
das ding ist die liefern uhr bis 23 uhr
und wenn die rezension im internet
stimmen das ist manchmal zwei stunden
dauert ist das ja auch schon viel zu
spät oder und ich würde auch sagen zwei
stunden ist echte lange zeit da kann
keiner drauf warten so dann bezahlt also
nicht also leute wir sehen uns gleich
wieder und ich mach paar updates mit
meiner bloggen kennt vielleicht so ich
habe also ich habe auf jeden fall
ungefähr und werde von 10 bestellt habe
um 21 54 hier diese sms bekommen und
zwar steht dann bestellen bei burger bc
30 minuten geliefert also eigentlich am
24 das heißt wenn man es noch neun
minuten
ich bin gespannt ob das wirklich nach
einer stunde geht ich werde mich wenn
dann liefern an da ist bis gleich
also leute die sachen sind angekommen
wir haben jetzt wo ist mein handy wir
haben jetzt halb elf ist hat eine 35
stunden gedauert aber es passt natürlich
trotzdem da werde ich jetzt gar nicht
mehr kann ist völlig okay für die zeit
also diese zwei stunden kann ich schon
mal nicht bestätigen wie sie so im
internet standen also die kritik und das
essen für recht warm an
deswegen würde ich sagen wir probieren
das wunder
let's go so leute also wir haben hier
zum glück die colaflasche und nicht in
diesem komischen plastikbechern evers
ist das in welcher papier bechern das
ist auf jeden fall schon mal gut willst
du lieber cola zero oder disco museum
das ist nicht so
hier ist ein schoko so hat schon mal
drin der sieht aus wie ja gut ist halt
wirklich so einen donut der da
wahrscheinlich schon zwei wochen drin
eingefroren ist noch frisch ist jetzt
nicht für 165 finde ich schon sportlich
aber ist natürlich dann hab ich schon
jetzt gucken wir mal hier rein
wir haben hier einmal die pommes finde
ich richtig gut die sind in so einer
festeren box als das eigentlich der fall
ist dann noch eine pommes und dungeon
lord schicken wird von den bürgern ich
bestellt habt den bacon bacon bürger
oder sogar aber es war und braucht
ketchup und mario also man muss an
dieser stelle mal sagen es ist alles
drin das ist ja leider oft der fall bei
solchen fast-food-restaurants dass man
dann durch den 13 fährt oder soda
mcdrive und man kriegt nur die hälfte
aber es ist alles da das schon mal gut
also bis jetzt war es doch richtig warm
volle punktzahl gefällt mir ich würde
sagen wir fangen doch einfach mal an die
pommes zu probieren die wirklich gut
sind dass wir jetzt wirklich für mich
sehr überraschen wenn das knackige
pommes sind vor allem weil es jetzt halt
liefert zeichen dass ich hat also die
müssen ein bisschen ruhig sein aber
schade also wirklich kostet jetzt nicht
hat man auch wenn man drauf bist echt
lange pommes aber ich habe also es ist
verständlich
natürlich verständlich darf ich den ball
kicken einmal vorher probieren es ist ja
letztendlich also die pommes es gibt
echt ein punktabzug
auch wenn ist verständlich ist wie
gesagt aber vielleicht könnte man das
trotzdem besser lösen
der dom schicken ist zwar warm aber
wirkt auch ein bisschen da bricht
nämlich leider fällt mir also an dieser
stelle der neuen schicken lecker
schmeckt frisch und ich muss auch sagen
die promis hier sind besser die kohle
auf jeden fall gut gekühlt schmeckt sehr
lecker wie eine ganz normale cola aber
ist ja auch logisch das einzige manko
hellwig rede mal wenn ich diese erstens
videos machen
das einzige mann nieder sagt man kann
nicht das einzige manko heißt es doch
nicht das waren bis jetzt die com ist
die rede wie so ein richtiger essens
testen ich könnte so eine restaurant
schon machen probiere ich nach sehr
langer zeit mal wieder einen fetten
burger den ich eigentlich niemals sonst
kaufen würde einfach aus dem grund weil
ich nicht so überzeugt von der
fleischqualität bin und sowieso nicht
mehr so gerne fleisch esse wie man hier
sehen kann sieht es jetzt auch nicht so
wunderbar aus wie es auf dem bild eben
außer aber das kennt man ja ich versuche
natürlich auch zu essen also hier muss
jetzt sagen man merkt bei dem bürger
dass er jetzt wahrscheinlich schon ein
bisschen eine liefert asche umlage bacon
ist auch überhaupt nicht wirklich groß
so wie ich denn wenn ich dann selber
machen am liebsten esse und für sowas im
menü mit den darin komme es dann 10 euro
zu verlangen ist meiner meinung nach
schon hoch angesetzt oder abzocke
natürlich kann ich verstehen dass der
preis ein bisschen höher ist weil es
liefert wird aber ich bin so jemand ich
gebe dann gerne auch nochmals zwei euro
trinkgeld für den lieferanten ich denke
nicht dass der lieferant irgendwas von
dem hohen bürgerpreis hat deswegen kann
ich da jetzt nicht verstehen warum der
bürger nicht wie im laden haus und
sieben euro mini kostet und sowieso
damit dass diese nicht allzu lange wird
probieren weil es eben noch den senat
von dem ich echt gespannt bin heißt doch
durchaus so was also derrick frisch ist
da nicht das weiß ich aber er wirkt so
also der donau hat ist sehr lecker
füllung ist gut schmeckt gut schmeckt
frisch wie gesagt ist er wahrscheinlich
nicht aber trotzdem gute punkt sollte
also insgesamt würde ich auf jeden fall
so eine 7 von 10 punkten oder man muss
sagen die lieferung zeit 45 minuten ist
ok für diese uhrzeit das bestellen
wahrscheinlich
billiger da ist leider waren die com ist
ein bisschen labbrig der bürger ist auch
ein bisschen labbrig aber ansonsten kann
ich jetzt nicht viel meckern ich meine
das habe ich auch erwartet ich bin
herzlich mit den besten erwartungen
gegangen
ja das war es mit dem video wie gesagt
lassen doch nach oben dafür offenbart
von irgendwas anderem könnt ihr mal in
die kommentare schreiben wo ihr gerne
hätte wir sehen uns morgen wieder morgen
gibt's neues video hat rein
check the prince tagoe war ganz wichtig
hiess